[Music]
yeah
yes is right Tracee Ellis Ross lay in
the AMAs from the get-go last night and
I'm not just talking about her hosting
well she had 12 looks including that
over-the-top iridescent Orange County
she owned it this she said I'm gonna
borrow that for a Thanksgiving dinner
what do you think perfect casual you
know of course all the ladies rocked the
AMA red carpet but it was Oscar winner
Nicole Kidman who literally stepped onto
the nights best-dressed list
can I just make a mention of this I'm
coming down this is okay you win the AMA
for best boots I'll make it Nicole told
me those $2,200 black corset over the
knee boots were made for dancing but
they weren't made for walking especially
when Keith won his three Awards I was
gonna drag her up there but she was yeah
she maybe didn't have the boots that
were gonna come up the stairs pass
tonight not a stair walking fashion a
good husband husband comes in many roles
but let's just say am a fashion was a
case of when one dress just isn't enough
demi went from sheer and strapless to
70s throwback with side cutouts newly
blunt Selena wore a coach leather moto
jacket as a mini dress then changed into
$145 white silk negligee and Kelly went
from black and gold sequins to sparkles
and feathers she tweeted I was queen of
Game of Thrones with a side of diva
hashtag winter came winter conquered
winter was a whole lot of woman what's
one beauty tip that you can pass on Oh
Laura
hire a team of people I have like three
Harry Potter's that just come in and
just change
tell me something we wouldn't know about
this about this dress we have to dye my
Spanx to make to match the color of the
dress because you could see through yes
I am obsessed with Diana Ross's
grandkids the little man bun on Bronx
and Jagger's mini doc martens and out of
all of Tracy's 12 looks our favorite was
this tribute to her mama
twinning with Michael Jackson this is
the actual original shirt which I found
in the garage and you asked what was I
doing in the garage I was shopping flash
feeling
and speaking of Diana so she hired a big
la stylist to get her ready for the
award show she ended up throwing out
everything all everything she wore was
from her claws that's pretty impressive
[Music]
you